hold on tight guys we are diving
headfirst into some major
kardashian-jenner drama and it is that
crazy on Tuesday a source told ET that
Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson
split after two years of dating because
of ongoing quote trust issues those
trust issues well that same day the 34
year old reality star commented on a
Hollywood unlocked Instagram post
claiming Tristan recently cheated on her
with dun-dun-dun
Jordan woods her sister Kylie's best
friend you cannot make this up people in
the post the Hollywood unlocked founder
Jason Lee claims that the rumors about
the two hooking up are true it was true
you know why cuz one of my writers was
there and Tristan you took everybody's
phone but you let them stay Jordan came
in y'all was smoking who cuz she was all
up in your lap you was all over her
touchy feely and you let the girl spend
the night till 7:00 in the morning now
that happened that's a fact
a little bit later he addressed Kylie
and the fact that Kylie your best friend
was at the house doin I like get her out
now and get him out too okay guys so
this is when it really gets good Chloe
commented on the post with shouting
emojis and her bestie Malika also
commented writing quote strong facts and
Kardashian family friend Larsa Pippen
chimed in writing amen then Malika being
the BFF we all need in life commented on
another post which showed Kylie's
daughter stormy quote waiting for Jordan
to pack her and get out of Kylie's house
adding and I quote these hoes ain't
loyal what the actual hell I wish I
could say that ends there but nope we're
just getting started
Tristan tweeted quote fake news after
reports broke of his and Khloe's breakup
he then quickly deleted it then Chloe
who has yet to comment on her own social
media posted this cryptic message on her
instace tori reading if your friendship
has lasted longer than seven years you
are no longer friends
you are family the
could be a dig at Jordan who has been a
big part of the kardashian-jenner family
for years now in fact Kylie and Jordan
had been best friends since eighth grade
when Will Smith's son Jaden introduced
them we met through a mutual friend she
grew up she's known Jaden like her whole
life and then I met him like in middle
school and like they were best friends
they still are Jordan was a regular on
life of Kylie appearing on the 2017
reality show for its one season
she told the t-shi be down for another
season of the series I would love that
but it's also you have to find the happy
medium of keeping your private life
private any personally you know it's
just saucy she was with Kylie when she
took her pregnancy test and in a June
video for Vogue Kylie revealed that her
pal had officially moved into her
Calabasas home I test out most of my
stuff on Jordan because we live together
so I'm like Jordan I need you Jordan has
even gotten involved in the
kardashian-jenner family business
modeling for Khloe's line good American
and for Yeezy season six
donning Kim's then blonde locks for
Kanye West's clothing line and if that
weren't enough to paint a detailed
picture of this tight-knit friendship
get this in September Kylie launched the
Kylie by Jordan line for Kylie cosmetics
she even had a Geordie lip shade in
honor of her friend you guys if the
rumors are true this is going to get
messy AF and if there is any truth to
the gossip it doesn't seem like Kylie
knew about it the beauty mogul was
hanging out with Jordan at her house
just hours before the news broke in fact
Kylie posted a snapchat of herself
before turning the camera on Jordan now
that is the face of someone who doesn't
know what's about to hit them and
despite all the chatter Khloe and Jordan
are still following each other on
Instagram Chloe even liked and commented
on Jordans posts the day before writing
baby girl
so maybe the rumors are wrong all this
drama comes after more than two years of
dating
and ten months after Tristan made
headlines when he reportedly cheated on
her with multiple women while she was
pregnant with their daughter true
Khloe gave birth to true last April just
days after the report broke and the two
eventually reconciled now a source tells
e.t quote she has to be strong for
herself and true everyone is extremely
disappointed of course this story is
still developing so be sure to subscribe
to all things ET for the latest as it
unfolds in the meantime I'm at Halle
underscore Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]